nous avions présenté une entrevue juste
à la veille de noël avec l'abbé gravel
une entrevue le fort touchante à
l'époque que vous avez été très nombreux
à réagir où il nous parlait de la mort
et nous parlait beaucoup de ces deux
soucis ses doutes quant à sa foi même
les difficultés d'approché la mort il
avait il a toujours le cancer du poumon
vous connaissez bien mon camarade alain
gravel
alain gravel alain crevier et pardonnez
moi alain alain crevier d'un second
regard
alain l'abbé gravel a tenu à vous
reparler parce que les choses
malheureusement vont pas dans la bonne
direction
non vous connaissez l'histoire en août
dernier le prenait de son médecin qu'il
avait un cancer du poumon métastases au
zoo avec un stade iv sérieux et et le
médecin lui a dit trois mois pas de
traitement six mois si vous faites des
traitements à la raymond a subi quarante
et une session de chimiothérapie
jeudi il est allé à l'hôpital pour des
tests vendredi il a été hospitalisé il
se trouve à l'hôpital de joliette où il
attend une place juste au dessus c'est à
dire aux soins palliatifs j'allais
rencontrer ce matin j'ai papa de moore
et j'ai pas de souffler ses poussins peu
de sympathie pour moi c'est les
confortant parce que je sais qu'au
moment du match change parce que
musulmane au médecin si je suis très
soulagée j'ai dit je vais la seconde
maintenant pour moi il dit aux soins
palliatifs y ait pas de problème à vous
enlever votre mal veille devant
l'engouement suscité chez vous le sur le
martin waeckel non je mangeais muette à
l'hôpital
comment comment il était serein comment
bon la mort approche là c'est très c'est
très déroutant parce que effectivement
il a pas l'air d'un mourant mais il faut
que je vous raconte quelque chose cette
semaine dimanche je suis allé le voir à
l'hôpital quand j'ai su qu'il était
hospitalisé
je suis à la joliette je les rencontre
et c'est être tout autre vraiment très
très faible avec pas beaucoup de force
pas beaucoup de voix mais on le traite
il a des plusieurs traitements et
notamment de la morphine et la douleur
qu'il ressentait dans ses épaules dans
ces zones cette douleur s'est dissipée
et aujourd'hui c'est un homme beaucoup
plus serein confort mais il faut pas se
le cacher et lui-même ne se le cache pas
c'est très fort probablement son dernier
était qu'il va vivre maintenant vous
allez voir c'est un homme quand même
très ému que j'ai rencontrés aujourd'hui
c'est la lettre de saint pierre pendant
le maire de ses pairs qui dit rendez
compte de l'espérance qui vous habite
hiltpold l'incertitude alors dépendre de
l'espérance que vous habitiez ce jeu
vers l'avant deux parties si les gens
peuvent retenir de ce plan l'espérance
de leurs espérances de vivre
l'expérience de vivre outre-mer aussi
parce que je crois qu'une vieille la vie
alors je pense que j'ai l'espérance de
vie boutemane même chose certaine si
j'ai blessé déjà je m'en excuse parce
que j'ai jamais voulu bien ces gens puis
moi j'étais blessé mais ce programme
pardon à tous ceux qui m'ont fait du mal
ça me dérange pas parce que je trouve
que pardon ça fait tellement du bien de
sa faire là dessus aussi
voilà c'est l'histoire de raymond gravel
qui se poursuit avec un cancer qui a
repris de la force malheureusement et
puis un homme quand même malgré tout
avec très ému mais très sympa très jeune
homme passionné que j'ai moi un lieu
connu à tahoua planétaire députés du
bloc les camps il
il se lancer dans un combat il y allait
entièrement
alors voila merci alain ça me fait
plaisir au revoir